Hey youtubers it’s charlie, happy wholock
week.
Hopefully you’ve all had a chance to watch
the doctor who christmas special by now.
Since there were a lot of references to all
era’s of doctor who going back to William
Hartnell I thought it would be fun to try
and find as many as possible.
If you saw my 50th anniversary easter eggs
video it’s a lot like that.
I’ll also be doing a peter capaldi specific
video this weekend as part of my ongoing wholock
celebration.
I’ve got a lot more Sherlock content coming
before the series 3 premiere too.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Heads up too, I’m giving away one twenty
dollar amazon gift card to a random subscriber
in the comments for this video.
Let’s get started this one’s going to
be a whopper, Number 1 - quick and dirty.
At sixty minutes, The episode is the shortest
episode ever broadcast on BBC1 featuring a
regeneration.
Technically the night of the doctor mini episode
only aired on the red service and the web.
In contrast, David Tennant’s final regeneration
in the end of time was two hours and fifteen
minutes.
2 - The Narrator.
Tasha Lem narrates the beginning of the episode.
This is the second episode to feature a narrator
at the beginning.
The other time was rassilon during the end
of time.
3 - All who came.
All of the spaceships you see in the wide
shot above trenzalore include, The Daleks,
the Cybermen.
the judoon, the sontarans, the sigh-lurians,
the terileptils, the slitheen family and the
church of the papal mainframe.
Although technically they’re an organization,
not a species.
The configuration of their ships is a visual
callback to the enemy alliance during pandorica.
4 - Not pictured.
The weeping angels, the monoid and the racnoss.
The weeping angels were also on trenzalore,
but they often travel on other people’s
spaceships.
It’s not fully explained how the landed
on the planet as tasha lem said that they
created a forcefield to prevent anyone in
orbit from entering the atmosphere.
The monoid isn’t seen on screen, but it
is depicted as a puppet.
The racnoss were not seen on screen, but were
depicted in one of the children’s drawings
on the wall of the clocktower.
It’s implied that they arrived and were
defeated sometime during the long siege of
trenzalore.
5 - The inverness cape.
Matt Smith is wearing an inverness cape similar
to the one worn by The Third Doctor.
Originally Jon Pertwee chose it as a joke
and wore it to a production meeting but it
stuck.
The third doctor character stole the inverness
cape during his debut episode spearhead from
space.
6 - Handles.
The reprogrammed cybermen head the doctor
is calling handles is a visual reference to
K-9 from the fourth doctor’s run and the
sarah jane adventures.
He even utters K-9’s signature phrase, Affirmative
Master.
7 - The phone.
This is the third time matt smith has used
the physical phone outside the tardis.
Despite the ninth doctor claiming that it’s
not a real phone during empty child.
It’s revealed that the doctor never uses
it because it’s typically patched through
the tardis console.
8 - Inventing a Boyfriend.
The doctor tells clara that he had an android
boyfriend once.
He is referring to Kamelion who was a companion
of the fifth doctor.
He was last seen in a picture on the unit
wall inside the black archives during the
50th anniversary special.
8 - Upgrades.
The cybermen in the episode are the alternate
universe cybus versions, later confirmed in
another drawing on the wall of the clocktower
which feature the phrase “Delete”.
9 - Clara’s mother.
The actress playing her starred previously
in the sontaran stratagem and in the sarah
jane adventures
10 - Clara’s grandmother previously starred
in vengance on varos during the sixth doctor’s
run.
11 - The apartment complex.
The apartment complex clara’s family lives
in is extremely similar to the one used in
the ninth doctor’s first episode rose.
Interestingly enough the doctor was carrying
around a hand for a large portion of that
episode.
Just like Matt Smith carries around handles.
12 - The doctor is naked.
Matt Smith also appeared stark naked in front
of amy pond during the eleventh hour while
he chose his new outfit.
The first time his character wore the bowtie.
13 - Holographic Clothes.
He and clara go to the papal mainframe naked,
and are still naked when they land on the
planet.
In a snowstorm.
Coldest game of twister ever.
14 - The Turkey.
They cook the turkey by exposing it to the
time vortex over the course of the episode.
Baking the turkey is also a metaphor for the
arrival of Peter Capaldi.
He’s baking inside Matt Smith for the episode.
15 - The Papal Mainframe.
The mainframe is just the spaceship headquarters
of the church.
Run by Tasha Lem.
You can think of it as a highly advanced version
of the church of england.
16 - Tasha Lem.
The actress playing her Orla Brady mentioned
during an interview that her character and
the doctor had a romantic relationship at
one point and that Tasha was a bit cruel,
but the doctor enjoyed her so much he always
forgave her.
There is a theory that she is actually a version
of River Song, the strongest piece of evidence
is that the doctor is only able to decode
the message from gallifrey with the seal of
rassilon.
But Tasha Lem had already decoded the message
before he arrived.
Which would have required time lord technology.
And the daleks said that they killed her several
times, which would have only been possible
if she could regenerate.
17 - The silents.
It’s revealed that the silents are actually
a genetically engineered order of preists.
They memory wiping abilities are merely to
prevent you from feeling guilty after confessing
your sins to them.
The silents trying to kill the doctor during
series 6 were a rogue sect called the kovarian
silents.
Named for Madam Kovarian.
They were the ones the blew up the tardis,
creating a bootstrap paradox, which the doctor
calls the destiny trap.
The silents went back in time to prevent the
doctor from answering the question by blowing
up the tardis, but in doing so created the
very cracks in the universe that allowed the
time lords to eventually ask the question.
you can’t change history if you’re already
part of it.
18 - The wig.
The Doctor got bored and shaved his head,
during these events he uses the wig to carry
a backup tardis key.
In real life Matt Smith had shaved his head
before production on the episode started for
his upcoming movie How To Catch a Monster.
So when they filmed the episode, he had to
wear a wig in real life.
Karen Gillan who appeared in the episode for
a brief cameo also had to wear an amy pond
wig because she had also shaved her head for
a movie, guardians of the galaxy.
In more distant doctor who history, the paul
mcgann had to wear a wig when he played the
8th doctor in the tv movie.
19 - Your ears are like rocket fins.
Clara makes fun of the doctor’s ears.
A nice visual call back to the 9th doctor.
we’re he said “could have been worse.
Look at the ears.”
during rose.
20 - The Truth Field.
We find out that the Time Lords are projecting
the truth field through the crack in the clock
tower along with the message.
We also learn that Clara really does fancy
the doctor.
We’ve always known the Doctor was a thief.
Also note that the townspeople ask the doctor
his name.
But he covers his mouth to keep from saying
it.
This is just a joke as he doesn’t know that
speaking his name is what the message is all
about yet.
21 - The doctor’s outfit.
The doctor changes into his outfit from the
2012 christmas special, the snowmen. and wears
it for the remainder of the episode until
he regenerates, changes back into his series
7 outfit and becomes peter capaldi.
22 - The Crack.
The doctor finds that the message is coming
from the same type of crack seen all the way
back in the eleventh hour.
Based on the events of series 5 and 6 he explains
the structural weakness in the universe that
is causing the cracks.
We also learn that this is what the doctor’s
biggest fear is, the thing he saw inside room
number 11 during the god complex.
At that time he didn’t know the time lords
were the ones poking holes in the universe.
He was merely afraid of the ‘weakness in
the fabric of the universe’ and all the
awful things that could happen as a result.
23 - The seal of the high council.
The doctor says that he knicked the seal of
the high council of gallifrey from the master
in the death zone.
The seal is a key to decrypt the message.
The doctor stole it during the events of the
five doctors when the master was sent to rescue
the doctors from the death zone.
24 - The first question.
The reason it’s called the first question
is because it’s being projected across all
of time and space.
Meaning that it’s playing at the birth of
the universe.
So it’s literally the first question to
ever be uttered.
25 - Doctor Who?
The voice speaking the question is the general
of the council of time lords seen during the
50th anniversary.
26 - What’s this planet called?
Trenzalore was the gravesite of the doctor
in the series 7 finale.
During that timeline the doctor never uttered
his name, but did not receive the new cycle
or regenerations.
Which is why we saw his corpse.
Because that’s point at which clara prime
jumped into his timestream and because the
doctor changed history during the 50th anniversary,
we can assume that the final resting place
might still end up being trenzalore.
But before the events of this christmas special,
he died during the siege of trenzalore.
27 - The Doctor Who Stayed For Christmas.
The doctor stays on trenzalore to keep the
alliance from destroying the planet and everyone
on it.
He’s staying more to help the people rather
than the time lords.
28 - The seige of trenzalore.
For the first 300 years of the seige the church
and the doctor uphold the truce by keeping
out all technology, not include the sonic.
Thus the wooden cyberman.
Which is actually played by a woman.
During the standoff he uses the classic 3rd
doctor phrase reverse the polarity.
29 - The Sonic Still Doesn’t work on wood.
Previously mentioned during the 2011 christmas
special the doctor the widow and the wardrobe
and during silence in the library.
30 - The Cane.
Matt Smith’s aging doctor is about 1500
years old halfway through the episode.
He is using a wooden cane similar to william
hartnell’s doctor.
He pokes the moniod puppet with it.
A monster last seen during hartnell’s run.
31.
The Dance.
The Doctor Teaches the children the drunk
giraffe.
As seen during the wedding of amy pond in
big bang.
32.
Clara rides outside the tardis.
Just like Captain Jack Harkness in utopia
in series 3 and the doctor himself during
hide in series 7.
33.
Reconnect the phone.
Before Handles runs out of power he reminds
the doctor to fix the phone.
Picking up the phone is a metaphor throughout
the episode.
From the time lords wanting the doctor to
pick up the phone and help them bring gallifrey
back, to tasha lem trying to call the doctor
when the daleks invaded the papal mainframe.
34.
Everything ends.
Everyone’s question about which number doctor
smith is and how many regens he’s used is
answered.
He tells clara he’s the 13th version of
himself in the 11th doctor’s body all thanks
to captain grumpy and the vain number 10 doubling
down.
so he’s got no more regenerations.
35 - The boy who waited.
Barnable asks the doctor if he’s coming
back and says he’ll wait.
the doctor smiles.
remembering little amelia pond during the
eleventh hour.
36.
Where are the pink ones?
It’s unclear whether or not the doctor is
eating jelly babies.
As the only other food smith’s doctor would
crave would be fish fingers and custard.
Which he eats before regenerating.
37.
Human Form Daleks.
A new creation of Series 7.
In the 300 years since the truce began the
daleks invaded and assimilated the papal mainframe.
Including tasha lem.
38.
The first doctor.
When clara returns for the final time the
doctor appears extremely old.
I’ve seen estimates anywhere from 600 to
900 years older than he was at the start of
the episode.
His hair resembles that of the first doctor
william hartnell.
39.
Extract from thoughts on a clock.
The poem that clara reads is by Eric Richie
Junior.
a character made up as part of the story.
It’s unkown whether steven moffat or mark
gatiss wrote the poem.
40.
The Name of The Doctor.
Clara tells the time lords the same speech
the doctor gave her during the series 7 finale,
convincing them to help the doctor.
The do so by granting the doctor a new regeneration
cycle of 12.
41.
Up in the sky.
A lot of people were confused about moving
the crack.
Because the universe is so weak the time lords
are able to punch holes in it at will.
Even though they could have sent the regeneration
energy through the crack inside the clocktower.
The sky crack is really just for dramatic
effect.
42.
Never tell me the rules.
This is just moffat poking fun at the fandom
for obsessing over the rule of 12 for the
past six months.
He’s just winking at us from behind the
camera.
Notice the glowy hands.
Smith’s regeneration actually started the
minute his body took in the new cycle of 12.
Meaning he’s using his first of that new
12 to become capaldi.
Start the counter, we have 11 regens left.
43.
It’s gonna be a whopper.
The doctor is regenerating for the 13th time
which is extremely unusual.
As a consequence he’s giving off more energy
during the process, enabling him to destroy
the inorganic daleks and their spaceship.
Regeneration energy doesn’t kill living
things, otherwise clara and everyone else
still alive in christmas town would have died
during the final blast of regeneration energy.
It’s likely that when capaldi eventually
regenerates, he’ll give off even more energy.
44.
Taking a bit longer.
The doctor we see is already completed the
majority of the regeneration process.
At the moment he’s just the echo of 11 and
the first whisper of 12.
Just enough time to think about an old friend
over some fish fingers and custard.
45.
Goodbye raggedy man.
The doctor remembers amelia pond as she was
a child and then as amy pond.
It’s not a bad wolf situation.
He’s just seeing her in his memory.
It’s been six years.
so the actress playing young amelia is different.
But Karen gillan returned to film the scene.
As mentioned earlier she and smith are both
wearing wigs as they were bald when this was
shot.
46.
Bowties will always be cool.
Smith dropping the bowtie is the last moment
of his run.
The bowtie belonged to his character just
like the scarf belonged to tom baker.
So don’t be surprised if capaldi doesn’t
wear any kind of neckwear.
47.
I’ve got new kidneys.
Peter capaldi’s doctor upholds the tradition
that new doctors always fixate on their new
physical features first.
48.
Do you happen to know how to fly this thing?
New doctor’s are typically disoriented after
regenerating, the 8th doctor didn’t even
know who he was.
And the tardis is crashing, pretty much the
same thing that happened when tennant regenerated
into smith.
49.
The final frame.
Clara’s reaction shot ending is the first
regeneration to end on a character that is
not the doctor.
There were so many interesting aspects and
facts to look at let me know if you saw anything
during the special that I didn’t mention
in the video.
This was super long, so if you made it to
the end.
You are a champ.
Remember i’m giving away a twenty dollar
amazon gift certificate to a random subscriber
in the comments.
I’ll be doing a peter capaldi predictions
video soon.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
Right now click here for my christmas special
q and a video and click here for my review
of the special.
Thanks so much for watching, high fives.
See you guys tomorrow!